some of us might be looking forward to a
vacation on a beautiful island this
summer yes please but not all islands
are equal when it comes to emergency
medical care there is one in the
caribbean where if your life is in
danger medical help may not arrive even
if an ambulance shows up our lead
national correspondent that of course is
david bagno traveled to an island off
puerto rico's main island and has more
on this story david good morning to you
yo good morning it is a beautiful island
when you book a vacation do you check to
see if there's an ambulance service that
will respond with trained medical
personnel and the equipment needed if
you have an emergency
most people probably don't
but that is the situation on coolabra
for the nearly 1800 year-round residents
and the tourists who helped to keep the
economy going
so we traveled by boat 17 miles from the
main island of puerto rico to kulebra
after we got word about recent drownings
on the island i want to warn you some of
the video you are about to see may be
disturbing
puerto rico's flamenco beach is
considered among the world's best
located on the island of kulebra
tourists flock here between 500 and 700
000 visitors visit the island every year
and they come to this beach
attorney julian rivera aspinall
represents the family of manny ma of
boise idaho the 62 year old ma drowned
while snorkeling off this beach last
december his wife found them floating
out in the ocean he was
eventually pronounced dead
and unfortunately there wasn't any way
of being able to save his life here at
the beach
there's been a grave danger here that
the locals know all too well
but the visitors almost never do
if your life is in danger
help is almost non-existent
when we were there there was not a
single lifeguard on the beach
did see this man using a whistle to keep
people from going too far out into the
surf he says he's a volunteer not paid
not trained he just wants to help i'm
thinking that i'm coming to this
beautiful beach and i'm gonna see a
lifeguard or two here i was surprised to
see no lifeguards while we were there we
met maria linden and julian rivera from
new york city and they asked what we
were working on so i explained to them
that not only did flamenco beach not
have lifeguards
there was no one employed as a certified
paramedic on the island
there's not even a working ambulance
stocked with the supplies needed to save
your life before the two of you came
here to visit culebra did you think for
a moment whether or not there was a
working ambulance no no you're just
telling me this time i'm stunned right
now
we wanted to speak with cool labor's
mayor el deberto romero yvette to find
out what's happening here just so i
understand you clearly you don't have an
ambulance staffed 24 hours a day here in
kulebra correct correct
that's scary see
because your
i mean your number one industry here is
tourism see
he's been the mayor here in kuwait for a
little bit more than a year and he says
he's trying to change things but the
high cost of living on the island and a
lack of certified personnel is making it
extremely difficult to employ
qualified medical professionals i need
paramedics i need a doctor i have a
technical uh
emergency emergency
i i need that people come to work in
culebra while the mayor waits on the
right people back on flamenco beach he
is taking steps to make the beach safer
installing bilingual signs red flags and
a lifeguard stand what do you think
about that well that's progress that's
great
again
i am very happy that the island of
culebra is eventually taking steps so
that these types of accidents don't
happen again my client's accident was
not the only accident that has occurred
here back in february of this year
sharoja paramanathan her husband thiva
and their kids traveled from toronto to
flamenco beach in culebra for a vacation
that is when the unthinkable happened
onlookers called 9-1-1 as good
samaritans administered cpr to the 40
year old father of three who they
dragged out of the water witnesses say
it took at least 30 minutes for an
ambulance just to show up they're not
emergency officials they're just two
drivers basically that's what they are
so this is essentially like a taxi yep
it's basically a taxi that says
ambulance
wow
do you feel like they did anything to
try and save your husband's life nope it
was just an easy
easy i know it's it's another another
person for them
it was it was just easy
sorry that's all you could do
sharogia's husband died
tomorrow you are going to hear more from
her and you're going to meet two of the
good samaritans who tried to save her
husband's life you will also hear
directly from one of the ambulance
drivers who arrived on the scene that
day
and what happened when he got there what
did he actually do
we'll tell you
this is so upsetting david because i
think when you go on vacation just
you almost let your guard down you
certainly don't think that you're going
to die on vacation and certainly not
snorkeling you think if it does somebody
will be there to help you take it for
granted you're going to call for help
and they come right that's what growing
up in the states wait until you hear
tomorrow when i say to the guy the
paramedic yeah when the states were used
to this wait until you see his reaction
but i want you to know that the good
people of collaborate you asked how many
people live there roughly 1800
permanently
they've been dealing with this for years
they've been begging
begging the island's government to fix
this yeah but the tourists that go there
don't know that right
that's what's so frightening but the
locals will tell you why does it take
tourists to fix what we've been ranting
about for years tourists dying bingo
right and why is the tourism important
because it's the number one the money
street there
i find it remarkable that the mayor
while you're saying those asking those
questions he's agreeing yes we don't
have paramedics look i think the mayor
wants to get it fixed he just doesn't
have the money and he just can't get the
people well i like him being very plain
about it yes you're right as opposed to
trying to explain well he's not running
away from it yeah yeah all right david
thank you we'll see you tomorrow part
two yes
we continue our reporting today on a
hidden danger at one of puerto rico's
top tourist destinations remember
yesterday we told you about the tragic
consequences when emergency medical care
never arrived in response to in response
rather to recent drownings on the island
of calabra this morning we hear from two
people who did try to help when a man
was in urgent need our lead national
correspondent david bagnow is back with
the story david your story was so
disturbing yesterday i can't imagine
it'd get any worse such an important
story i think so too today we'll hear
from the two people at the scene
we told you about the two families
yesterday whose lives were changed
forever when they went on vacation to
the paradise island of culebra there was
manny ma the man from utah who drowned
while snorkeling and then there was the
heartbreaking experience of sharusha
paramanathan from canada who waited
helplessly for an ambulance to arrive
after her husband drowned on flamenco
beach here is part two of our report
beginning with more of our interview
with sharoja i want to warn you some of
what you are about to see is disturbing
finally the employees came
the person i remember asking
somebody asked if they if they know how
to do cpr and i remember him asking
what's cpr
so at that time i kind of lost my
hope sharoja paramanathan says she was
holding out hope that once they got into
the ambulance there would at least be
some type of life-saving equipment like
a defibrillator that could help to
resuscitate her husband it's
empty
it's empty they come with an ambulance
it's completely empty there's no machine
nothing nothing in there her husband was
taken to calabrese only clinic and that
is where he was pronounced dead i'm sure
if it happened toward or he'll be alive
right now
that's what i know right now
if they would have done more he would be
alive for sure
for sure
i'm from sri lanka and
i've been in
the indian ambulance in sri lanka and
it's a third poor country and they have
much better vascularity than this much
much better facility emily jimenez a
certified medical assistant and emily
boca the registered nurse were there
with their young families on vacation
they were two of the good samaritans on
the beach that day when the emergency
happened they didn't know each other
before this and they have not seen
sharoja since then what is it like for
the two of you just listening to her
it's heartbreaking
i've had every feeling that you can
imagine from anger to
frustration to sadness there's people
that live there
what kind of care are they getting
i told the same emily when i left that
hospital i told them like
this got to change i mean what happened
to us shouldn't happen to anybody else
do you remember saying at some point
where the heck is the ambulance yes
multiple times
yep
i was the one doing compressions when
they showed up
and i just looked up and i said hey
we're all exhausted is there any way you
guys could take over for us or help us
what did they say they said just said no
we don't do them out here
so what were they doing standing around
just watching y'all yep standing around
emily jimenez recorded this video
ambulance takes over 30 minutes then
they come with no equipment
they refuse to give him cpr there is one
resident living on kulebra who says he
is a certified paramedic he even posted
on his facebook page about passing the
test his name is david perez
in fact he was one of the first
responders to arrive on the beach that
day when good samaritans were trying to
revive sherrod's husband all right so
you and another person responded to the
scene yes i it is driver only driver and
so what were you there to do
a sister chauffeur
assist the chauffeur yes
my job prescription is the technician
the emergency management no ent no
paramedic
no not in the health the salu i hear you
but i'm just struggling david because
you are a paramedic so i understand
you're not working for the municipality
as a paramedic
but when this happened you were trained
as a paramedic so
why didn't you
offer to help
with the cpr or with anything else
he claims that once they got into the
ambulance he performed cpr
charusha told us that never happened in
my experience in the states
paramedics just always jump in right
they always just jump in and take over
puerto rico
it's not even support police and i
appreciate the candor but
it's also kind of sad
i would like to see
the people that were responsible to
assist but chose not to be held
accountable
i would like to see the government you
know use the funds that
they have and utilize them
to make an island safe and so what did
the two of you think walking away
i assumed they were going to give care
but i felt just sick about it all
that that man did not
get the justice of care that he needed
sick why
there's so many things that just basic
things that could have given him a
better outcome
and we didn't have any of that
we weren't able to give him
the best care we could have would you go
back
i don't think so
i feel like it's too big of a risk
especially with my family
at this point
there has to be something done
five days after we left crew labor a 58
year old man died after drowning on
flamenco beach
now the mayor's office tells us they
have since hired a lifeguard who began
working on may 14th and that there have
been no reported drowning since
now get this the puerto rico public
safety department that oversees all of
puerto rico's islands told us in a
statement that in kuwait there are two
municipal paramedics one of them that's
certified
so we went back to the mayor's office to
say hey did you hire someone since we
were there do you now have a paramedic
you know what they told us
no
we haven't hired anyone but the
lifeguard
i'm telling you if i was thinking about
a trip to calabra i'd be rethinking it
right about now for sure i'm fascinated
by that paramedic who sat down and
talked to you and just admitted no i
didn't do anything and he was aware that
someone died he was aware and he's still
saying this to you i don't get it it's
in his own words now let me say this q
they thrive on tourism yeah there will
be people who watch this story who say
this is going to hurt tourism i want to
be very clear
this is not an attempt to hurt tourism
this is waving a giant red flag to say
that in a united states territory it is
unacceptable right to not have a single
paramedic or a working ambulance
available 24 hours a day and the
island's government can do something
about it in fact last night we were on
the phone late at night and we found out
that apparently there's some type of
effort in the works for the island's
government to help coolabra and send
medics over from the main island but
it's a distinction well they knew it
sooner rather than later immediately the
mayor you spoke to yesterday he
acknowledged that there was a problem
totally he did acknowledge that
and they should fix it it's a stinging
indictment when uh shiruja says that in
sri lanka what she admits is the third
world country where she is from that
there are better facilities uh and this
wouldn't have happened there
than a territory of the united states of
america and then when you have the nurse
emily who says that you know they he
would still be here if he had gotten and
i know there are locals on the island
who are watching this saying david we've
been dealing with this for years yeah
and it took tourists dying for this to
get the attention that we've been asking
for i could see why that would be
upsetting i was wondering how it could
get worse today and it did yeah and i'm
glad you're telling it yeah we pride
ourselves on this type of reporting
which is exquisite but this is important
because it can save lives bingo david
thank you